hi my name is Ayanna Halley hi my name
is Leah savay Jeffries and this is
tricks of the tree
[Music]
for me I made sure that I watched a lot
of YouTube videos because again I was
like it's nowhere we're going to be
filming with an actual line so watching
the YouTubes and seeing like how this
lion reacts and how they attack people
and stuff really helped me not just see
a man in this outfit but see like a lion
and literally fight for my life so
that's what I had to do to prepare I did
have to prepare because I I didn't
expect of course like a real life animal
to be there but I didn't expect a guy in
the gray suit to be there also this is
gonna need a lot more imagination than I
thought it would be you know you've been
to zoos and stuff of course to see a
lion but you don't know their real
natural habitat so just like what Ayanna
said about going online and checking to
see how Lions act or react to certain
things actually when we first flew into
Africa Vault the director he had like
this what do you call it like it was
like a version of it in cartoons Leah do
you remember like I feel like the girls
looked like us it was an animation films
instead of a guy in a gray suit it was
actually how the line's supposed to look
little clip of it it was definitely
helpful
um because we film a lot of the scenes
in a car so in this thing that he
created it kind of showed like how the
car would be rocking and stuff so for me
I'm like oh okay that's how it's gonna
look so it helped me for sure
when we got to South Africa for the
first three weeks I saw him actually
walking past me every day he would be
like okay I'm gonna be coming this way
with you in this way I thought he was a
cameraman and I was like oh okay that's
strange it's like you're running towards
me I was like oh okay until when
actually that day when we started
filming and he was in a gray suit and he
was like okay I'm ready I was like he is
definitely not a cameraman I was like he
is the Beast I'm like like we need to
give prop to props to this guy because
he was going all out on this he gave us
the sound effects which was cool too and
for me I was kind of nervous because I
actually interact with them with the
lion right so I'm like okay I'm really I
don't want to be fighting a man I'm like
uh so he's like no like don't be scared
like hit me do whatever and I'm like
okay it's like imagine it's a real line
so I had to really just like not see
this man but see the Beast literally
I think it enhances it just because you
can do so much and have so many
different characters without us ever
using the real thing like to have a
whole film about a lion basically trying
to survive as well as us trying to
survive and never having to actually
interact with the lion and just use CGI
and visual effects I think it's pretty
cool you can create this whole world of
things without ever you know having to
interact with it or anything even
Jurassic Park all those cool movies it's
just CGI it looks pretty real
you guys are absolutely amazing you guys
really made it real for us and even
giving us the things that we need in
terms of like sound effects when it's
needed or just the way they put things
together is super helpful I think Beast
had an awesome Team all around you are
not lying about that I totally agree
[Music]